we're way past our time Bretton so we're
gonna do the thing called unhelpful
advice but I'll lead you into it what do
we do on helpful advice
Sarris read my text I apologize I'll see
your family some girl Charlotte just
Tecna needs money invest you've done a
podcast before would you do this again
your guys know we bought a house you
know that I love it and there's a studio
in we have a nice place but um we would
love yet to have you back when we're in
the new place literally whenever you
want I just can't believe this is the
first time you're doing it I mean we've
had a bunch of people on a bunch of
times and for you for you on a Tuesday
morning
you guys I woke up early in the morning
to wake to do yours one o'clock is I'm a
comic your kid though what is that I
always get up what is that what is that
like it's the best thing in the world
makes you realize that like no but going
into it before he was born
did you I was so selfish I was so
selfish but selfish because I'm in
entertainment and as an athlete like you
got to be kind of a narcissist it's all
about you the world revolves around you
then we have a kid I'll be honest
everyone gets dude right when he's born
you know this connection it's gonna be
crazy oh my god I can't wait he comes
Alma not really there he's just like a
football with the eyes he needs his mom
so bad I'm like this side piece that
makes sure that they don't die yeah but
like his his grandmas they're in their
taint Cara I'm sleeping on the couch
when this [ __ ] sucks yeah and then
probably like three months into it he
starts to get you know a little bigger
like figure things out and it's lit the
best thing in the world when like I've
done cool stuff in my life man through
football you know even sniffin the NFL
and playing in [ __ ] big college
football games fighting you have seen
some biggest fights in the world
sold-out arenas I mean sold-out theaters
and stand-up and shooting a stand-up
special just bought a Ferrari like but
my dream house right I'm not Brad
I've done cool [ __ ] man nothing compares
when I come home from this at 4 o'clock
my son runs up and hugs me goes Daddy
and runs up to me not so that's why I
can't do podcast Monday night that's why
when people ask me to do stuff I can't
do it that's got that's why when Bravo
goes hey we want you to a show in New
York would pay this much money you could
pay me
Beyonce money I'm not going out there
I'm telling you man
I've done cool [ __ ] there's nothing
better than having a kid if you're a
good dad would you consider even before
you had the kid did you know that you
were gonna be a good dad and just of
providing and making sure that the kid
was safe that's what we're concerned
about no way Bobby but Bobby's are good
he's a good she's gonna figure it out
he's going to offer time and fun and
obviously a lot of those like emotional
things right but leave his medication on
the counter every day for the kid to
open probably I'm Toni she won't because
the kid's gonna be around and you
realize how fragile they are and you
know the world becomes so scary so we
might get that school today and this is
weird I have to anxiety like I've never
had before about my son I gotta worry
about he's in a popper school Mike what
a shooter go there so I started looking
at other schools now I be ice to be and
he's three I used to be that guy like
Bob Atlas leave things out one thing
everything your mind changes everything
changes and I guarantee though because
if it doesn't change guaranteed is
guarantees disease not a bad person
he's not you anyt be with him if Bobby
Wright guarantee you will change and I'm
sayin Simon to change you don't know
what's happening like my financial
adviser goes remember when Itoh we're
gonna have a kid I go yeah goes let me
show you the income you had before he's
born let me show you a year later I'd
sub caution to anything I just went into
this dad mode I'm like oh [ __ ] I got a
kid on the way I need to get my [ __ ]
together and I already had my [ __ ]
together respect you know kind of yeah
but you just naturally going this dad
mode and all these other revenue streams
start coming in or this thing I was
thinking about doing I [ __ ] did it
now it's killing it for me this thing
over here I'm think about touring this
much I keep my tour that much
so all these certain things started
happening just subconscious a poppin out
it happens wow that's incredible your
that was the bet that was the best
pitch I've ever heard when it comes to
kids and I don't say that to everyone
there's certain people go to shaft kids
I go I don't know man you gotta figure
it out because kids are so you know I'm
just like now you figure it out that's
me being like [ __ ] no yeah but there's
certain people I mean I'm like you gotta
have kid that was dumb here's my thing
Bobby and I don't know you that well but
the time I start with Bobby the world's
filled with [ __ ] sometimes [ __ ] people
you owe it to the world insist you owe
it to people that like I do because
because you're a good person you've gone
through experiences that you can pass
down to a child that's where it gets a
little hairy because him and I both have
murderers and our family's addiction oh
come on but eugenics we real killer no
you're not you've learned you know we're
not but also those serial killers will
ship keeping and family start because
their shitty parents serial killer kids
[Music]
yeah I mean your kid is like [ __ ] the
new Cho seung-hui or something your kids
no ever kids no I gotta get going that's
between I know I'm good give it up me
when he was 60 gotta get it going get a
freeze-frame on that face yeah like
feels dad was 70 yeah yeah that's what I
heard that was the same do you have
demons from it do I have demons from it
what kind of demons you tell me I do
yeah there you go yeah I think that
growing up with a really old dad was
really difficult because I saw him
withering away and the weirdest part
about it not weird I I regret it now but
I didn't understand it as a child but
when my dad would come visit me in
school I was ashamed because everyone
was like oh your Grandpa's here and I'm
like and I would try to like furniture
I'm not being mean at all I feel [ __ ]
up about it Nam like why didn't I
but I was embarrassed of my gray-haired
old father but when you kid you don't
realize it like I had a friend whose dad
was super old I remember he was super
embarrassed about it so that's why I
asked you have deals because he is I
don't call him demons he has my odd
Saint monsters yeah but Steve Martin was
in the 60s right when he had a kid you
think his kid is embarrassed too Steve
Martin not now as a child if you're a
kid and Steve Martin's your dad you're
like yeah that's my daddy's all baby
Steve Martin he's one of the biggest
names in the world so I think it's a
little different but in general like
shock to feel about I think you look at
the world different when your dad's like
you know you're in your you're 1415 he's
dying man like what the fuss is showing
on him and it's not like my dad was some
like decrepit old man and I was younger
either he would come in he looked like a
mafioso he would always come in a suit
dark glasses [ __ ] attache case all
the time like he was he was like James
Bond
but even then Father Time was cool story
let me touch you on this but even then
he was a gray-haired obviously older guy
and I just didn't want my friends to
know that that was my job it's a bummer
it's so [ __ ] sad I wish I met him
yeah he was dope
[Music]